[Music]
welcome back to
the record where we talk about whatever
we want
and everybody's back soy's back cat's
back
yup we're back that's so true what kind
of questions you want to know about us
yeah we we grilled you last time i do
have a lot of questions
how did you guys meet all of us which
one yeah
so i guess if you guys seem like a
pretty tight like friend group but
you guys have some history with the
whole cop story so i was like oh like
have you guys known each other your
whole lives they met first yeah they go
away we met
in two thousand we built this company
okay like 2004 huh
at the mma gym yeah yeah we met at an
mma
gym through mutual friends we went to
the same high school and community
college but we didn't really know each
other
and then we just like goofed around all
the time and then um
we started we realized the same sense of
humor so we started a youtube channel
together and that was like 2007
it's like three years after we met we we
hung out with the same people
three years before we met yeah but we
didn't know each other
because when i left the high school he
came in
so there's an h-cap no we're the same
age but i um i left not graduated i
signed myself out oh you mentioned it
yeah yeah
yeah and then when i came in i got
kicked out of another high school
they're just swapping around yeah and
then so fast forward to
2007 we started doing youtube videos
2009 you came around 2009
he came around he was our first like uh
direct main direct yeah videographer
filmed everything edited
yeah yeah and then um fast forward
we built all these different channels
whatever whatever we got
we got these plaques i want to show off
real quick yeah we got hella plaques
girl yep let me [ __ ] oh she got a lot
we gotta post these somewhere all right
so uh we're gonna be proud of it we got
just kidding
party we have a hundred thousand subs
here we go we have asked a few hundred
thousand subs
we got just kidding we got this gold
play button
that's the original one too the new one
looks different yeah the new one that
one
i like this one better backing i have
the new one it's not as cool that's
that's cool
this thing in it we got this that more
stylized
the difference between these two oh
film's new though yeah films and news we
got this
and then so that looks pretty sick on
camera yeah we all built this
we all well built this and then and then
i'm trying
to fast forward
what bitcoin can i get for that goal
it's all scratched up too
and they're missing we have another one
that we submitted for
and they haven't sent it to us yet but
we have another channel that had a
million subs which one yeah just kidding
party um that was news that's right
we need one more oh you have to submit
yourself to get it
yeah but we've been waiting for three
years it's pretty automated yeah
and well anyways no maybe we've been
waiting for five years for them to send
it to us
but it's okay dusty you don't give those
things in your life
we leave it under yeah uh we're not
proud of it
fancy paperweight here steve came around
i want to say 2014 15 15
2016. oh because we met nikki his wife
first
in 2014 she came around 2014. yeah
we had her and and and uh starring in
our videos
and then we went to jk news and asked
the fields a lot too yeah she's one of
the few females that we met that was
really open with like talking about sex
and stuff so it was cool to have she was
funny
yeah she was great and yeah and then we
saw
uh you know tim timberlake yes yeah yeah
we had a roast on him
and he had this whole event and steve
roasted him and i'm like
oh my god this guy's hilarious wait you
did say your fiance or whatever was or
husband
was a comic and then it just i never put
the two together and i'm like
let's bring them and then that's when
steve started hanging with us
yeah we hit it off like a [ __ ]
like it was crazy like i remember coming
in this room because
you you're a youtuber you do so many
collab videos over the years i'm like an
og youtuber too i was in
this game since like 2008 2009 and
you do so many collab videos with so
many [ __ ] douchebags and then i met
you guys
and i i was expecting you guys to be
tools nikki said you guys were cool
but i always go into everything just
going like i'll i'm expecting to be
disappointed yeah yeah yeah yeah and
then we'll just see if they
if it happens right but you guys are
[ __ ] legends
and like everyone's so cool and
welcoming and [ __ ] so
i was just like damn i told nikki i was
like i could do that every week and i've
never left a collab video doing that
and i ended up doing this a lot so being
with us for like
five years now yeah yeah yeah yeah cause
i barely know joe but i just entered the
room and i was like well everyone seems
like pretty like friendly and nice and
nothing's been super hostile but i was
just wondering because it seems like a
cool environment
and we met kat um a couple weeks ago a
couple weeks ago yeah because i
uh met nadeem on instagram we followed
each other because he watches the
podcast i work for
i watched jk films since i was a shy
literal child
what did you tag him too and they go for
bro that's the thing
i was at the
2014. yeah yeah and i was like
what that's crazy so she was watching
our content it was a literal child
watching uncles now you're here now they
influenced you they
absolutely actually and probably a
negative way
[Laughter]
put therapy for this only positive ways
i feel like
no but no lie i think jk is a big reason
why i am in my career now only because
like
at a certain point when i was growing up
there were like
asian people who were known as like
model minority and you guys were
like [ __ ] neanderthal
i love that like you guys had similar
energies to like bobby leah like do you
have margaret
whoever the [ __ ] you guys want yeah yeah
yeah and so i always kind of spoke my
mind and then that's how i got on
fighting the kitten kingdom
oh you're like where's my degenerate
people there
this this is my people yes my people i
saw i was like this is
this is exactly what i need in my life
that's true
the gutter asians are not represented
equally i tell you
they we exist god damn it you know but
it's it's almost like
it's funny because when you look at the
asian scope right of
of who's like out there and they talk
about no representation right
i almost feel like we're this
embarrassing group where they're like
representation but like not you guys but
you guys that's how i [ __ ] feel you
guys the ones who taught me that like
representation means
calling everything asian like calling
everything
it's an asian thing it's an asian thing
like well no not just the asian thing
but you you you
said that you didn't go to one college
thing that wasn't didn't have asian in
the title of it
like in some way where you're like why
does it always have to
rhyme with asian people or celebration
and beijing like those things i'm like
yes mine's so [ __ ] cheesy i had no
idea that it even existed
and then now every time i see that i
always cringe for you guys
i get it now right yeah so then we had
um what's her name from um
from the bling show on bling empire we
had kelly yesterday
yeah she and she was awesome she's great
she's a different
spectrum of the asians the most father
of asia i've ever met and she got to
make something that didn't have to
have asian in it it's just so cool which
i wouldn't have never even
known was cool until i met you guys and
you guys taught me that i'm like oh wow
that's [ __ ] cool
yeah but yeah it's just you learn so
much from just different
having different perspectives yeah i
feel like it's almost probably like back
in the day like every
italian i wanted to make a movie was
like it had to be mafia based
and then they're like can i just make a
regular italian story or something
that's not
and i think for us it's the same thing
where we see all asian content it's
always like this
and then so i guess like bobby lee was
probably even before us where he just
kind of did his own [ __ ] thing and
then we did our own thing
but then also i know he's in his own
world too i don't even know if he's
he's even asian that's sure yeah he's an
alien yeah he's just an alien
but yeah i think it's cool that we just
kind of did our own thing and we had a
decent amount of success i guess
that's so much success i i've heard of
you guys but i i didn't grow up watching
youtube so it's not like a whole like
oh i only watched this thing like i grew
up like in k-pop so it was either you
like k-pop or youtube yeah so i was like
really into k-pop so like when i moved
to l.a everyone's like oh like
wong fu jk michelle like all this stuff
and i was just like i don't
i never grew up with like any of this
yeah but it's really cool to see like
asians
like doing cool things online period not
wong fu though but yeah yeah yeah
they're they're weird yeah no they're
not not one food yeah i think it was
like one of those
things where um when you're in l.a
like you like you two probably relate
more because you're
like not the majority right but when
you're
in la or when you are the majority you
it's like fish and water they don't know
they're in water like we
don't know how good we got it right
because i mean
even for me right like i grew up mainly
like with black mexican
and some asian but it's still more than
maybe what you
you two went through right but then when
i moved here
it was like oh damn and i looked on
wikipedia monterey park has the highest
concentration of
uh asian population in america period
whoa
yeah so we are in the city of the
highest number
which is about 80 percent you know so it
was like there's a lot in this room i'll
tell you that
it kind of reflects right more than i am
more than 80 yeah more than 80 percent
this
episode is brought to you by babel
bamboo
the number one selling language app and
i'm actually really interested in this
because you know my wife gio is mexican
and she speaks spanish and grandma comes
over and talks to taika in spanish all
the time so they
all are speaking in spanish and i'm just
tired of them like talking [ __ ] about me
i need to know what the hell is going on
and those three
filthy mouths and i was trying no i'm
just kidding
i was actually trying to really learn
how to speak spanish just because it's
you know such a common language and i
did
buy like this cd style one yeah but i
think it was
you know when things are too like
theoretical two textbooks
yeah it's like you're teaching me
phrases that no one is ever gonna say
yeah teach me pandejo
like someone cuts me up i know what to
scream out the window
yeah not senor right yeah so i want to
learn something like that and i heard
that babel is really really good because
a lot of it is very practical
usage and they even have a speech
technology thing right where you can
kind of slowly like you speak into it in
the correctional enunciation
i tried it for german and i i do think
that there's a reason why they're the
number one
language selling app right now like
they're the number one selling
language app right now on the market is
because they have this voice like
technology where
when you are um told like a phrase or
whatever right
you speak it in to the program and then
they
correct you your pronunciation and all
this stuff so it's almost like
it is having a language teacher
basically it's just ai though
yeah and my favorite part of it is that
the lessons are only 15 minutes long
so you can technically do it when you're
taking a poop
going for a walk like they're they're
short lessons it's not a giant
commitment
we're like okay i hope this drives an
hour long like you can use it
just little by little and fit it into
your day and it's super useful
well what i like about it too is that
there's like a hundred
plus language experts that got together
and i like to believe that they had this
like king arthur and the knights of the
round table not a giant donut desk
oh that's pretty cool too they could
face each other they're facing each
other and then but they're
in the nights though and then like
they're the knights of language yeah and
then they're
like an official committee helping the
program
learn the right way of like how do you
learn a language not the boring way
yeah yeah and also if you're
if you don't want to learn spanish
because you already speak it or whatever
there's 14
languages on the app and i thought that
that was pretty cool that is really cool
so
german italian french yeah so if you're
interested in learning another language
in
a very easy to digest format you want to
be able to speak
and improve your enunciation go to
babel.com that's b
a b b e l dot com and use the code off
the record because i have a really good
deal right now
for three months you pay you get six
months total you get three months
and you get the next three months for
free so go to babel.com
and use the code off the record to get
your six months
for the price of three months yeah but
then because of that though when we
first started making
content it was like hey you know what's
funny
is like all this comedy stuff i just
don't get it like
there are asian comics but then i feel
like i don't connect with their jokes so
we started doing
stuff because we just thought it was
funny and then a lot of people started
talking about like
asian representation you're doing it for
this and that and i was like oh [ __ ]
yeah you're right it is like that
but i guess i will like that fan
yeah he was the san diego comic i
remember him growing up like because i
was yeah he was crushing about that yeah
he was
he was good yeah yeah i liked him too
actually but it became fun to hate that
fan so then everyone
i know right i think bobby started all
of that [ __ ] yeah
like oh gee tiger belly days she [ __ ]
hates tattoos so much that was the dean
cook thing dan cook came up hard and
then everyone started to hate on dane
cook and they became not cool to like
dance yeah
i remember being at ucd in 2006 and
everyone's like [ __ ] dan cook and that
would get a laugh every time
so like so stuff like that you see that
and how that all builds and
it's all [ __ ] but it works that's so
funny but yeah dad fan man
everyone loved to hate that fan because
bobby started it
that's crazy i do feel like though right
now there's this whole
new um what do you call it not emergence
like there's always been like this thing
of like
defining culture right but there's now
this whole new way
of looking at it it's and it's different
from when we grew up
and what is like cool asian [ __ ] you
know because
back then it was like youtube was the
only place
like that you will see i guess asian
american youth culture
but then now it's not just like
it's not one thing like before it was
one thing but then back then it was like
within cape like i mean now it's like in
in k-pop which is like a mesh of the two
right or like
anime jimmy's really big too yeah you
know yeah and then um
even all the asian influencers don't
know each other
right but 10 years ago we all knew each
other
like because it was either just youtube
wait it was only youtube
and then traditional yeah and then that
was that was even more of a closer
thing too yeah but now it's like you got
the 88 rising kids you got like
even like different youtubers that just
are asian but they don't hang out right
yeah also like take talkers there's a
bunch of asian tic tacs
true yeah and they're on their own from
like it's so interesting
instagram instagram yeah you see it's
kind of dude tick tock
there's a bunch of tick tockers who are
getting their own reality show right now
oh yeah they're under fire right there's
like that netflix show that
just got announced and people are angry
about it why are they angry
because they don't like the idea of
tick-tockers having a lot of success
because
like no like i mean who is it who is
angry thank you for saying that
that's why we like you i would say it's
like the general
public of like it's the same people who
[ __ ] on tick tockers before they made
money
because they're like oh look these
stupid kids like doing stupid dances
like they're idiots
and now that they're multi-millionaires
getting these netflix deals and whatever
the [ __ ]
people are like well i could have done
that and their heads are like i should
have done that but i didn't so i'm going
to hate on them
but that's what happened to youtubers
yeah comedian stand up comics
comedians on youtube and now i can't get
away from anybody
any of my the people that i watched as a
kid or anybody at the end of the video
saying thanks for watching please
subscribe and i'm like
back in the day you [ __ ] used
to make fun of us yeah you laughed at us
we were on youtube hating ourselves
we were on youtube resenting youtube
yeah
because i'm like what i used to go to
panels and like uh
i am not a youtuber i'm a filmmaker
oh you're the like pretentious like i'm
not the part of them
you know what's funny because all right
in 2000
i want to say from 2007 to maybe like
2013 even right og youtubers
we got on youtubers because we had no
choice because
it's like hollywood was so [ __ ] hard
we just pivoted or we just had fun with
it
nobody wanted to be a youtuber but the
kids that grew up
watching youtube their dreams were to be
a youtuber
because our generation paved the way for
that right
and then now you're welcome but then now
it's like
it's not weird right it's just a thing
like if you're a youtuber you just make
youtube videos
but i remember there was a time when
musicians on youtube were like no i'm
not a youtuber i'm a musician
or like i do this i'm a pianist or
whatever
that's why i flew to new york and i did
a troll video outside of the
youtube music awards and it was
hilarious because we had all these
youtubers who do music
who didn't get nominated and it was like
eminem got nominated like a dell oh yeah
oh i remember that so then i went to the
i was
in line there with my microphone on my
camera and [ __ ] and i was
asking people i was like who's your
favorite youtuber and then i was like
why isn't it like eminem why isn't it
like
lady gaga they all post videos on
youtube they are youtubers like why are
you talking about all these people
nobody's ever
[ __ ] heard of like yeah which is the
joke of it because
what the [ __ ] was youtube even thinking
not promoting their own people yeah but
that's how it's been the whole time
youtube hates its own creators
it does and they can't wait for some
celebrity to come in and then boost
youtube make it cooler right yeah but
then youtube people who are watching are
like i don't know this person and that's
what the magic of youtube is they feel
like they know us
i remember being a part of youtube
comedy week like i got the email in and
i'm like
[ __ ] yes finally i'm getting included in
something official
youtube part of the whole comedy thing
and then
uh i show up and then i look at the
script and all they needed me for
because it's already filled with all the
legit stand-up comedians
um it was just me that was laying on the
ground as a dead person the whole time
oh my gosh so i was like you got to be a
trainer i was like hey this is better
than that that's how i just lay there
and then [ __ ] it you know nothing
yeah i was cast as a person i was just
laying on the ground because i was dead
which is symbolism yeah yeah yeah yeah
to real youtubers
yeah they really [ __ ] on us
foreshadowing i know
right and i'm like who the [ __ ] are i
mean i knew i knew who the standard
comedians were but i'm like who the [ __ ]
are you guys to our audience you know
and that's why i didn't the comedy weeks
didn't go on very long because
people were tuning in to see their
favorite youtube comedians but it was
just a bunch of stand-up comedians
isn't that why they stopped making
rewinds like last year they didn't
actually do a youtube rewind they were
like
we're the top uh videos for these
categories
mr beast made a pretty legit rewind
though because
you know he understands youtube he's a
you you know and then he made it
he's like a youtuber through and through
not necessarily because he grew up
watching youtube he
wanted to yeah some people i feel like
get on youtube for like the
like quick chat they try to be better
than me yeah
who tried to be like oh i'm a youtuber
now guys but it's still like
no you're an actress coming in here
trying to like make money off your
audience or whatever the [ __ ] because
your agent told you to do this [ __ ]
but like you're not sure yeah and it
shows and it absolutely shows and every
now and then you'll do a
[ __ ] mukbang with some like creator
that you know
and that's about it but you're not like
a youtuber user mr beast is a youtuber
right
and that's a successful one i did a
video with margaret show years ago
thinking it was gonna be like that
because it was like you know whatever
but she was so [ __ ] cool i was like
okay that's cool
i i judged this wrongly shouldn't have
done that
but but but yeah mostly it's the other
one yeah
mr beast is sick though i love watching
his videos he can get me any time
every time his [ __ ] is just like crack
dude i'm like
i don't know how he does it but i want
to watch all this [ __ ] you know
bieber i consider him like a youtuber he
is absolutely bieber is a youtuber
yeah but you know they don't
promote him as a youtuber some people
outgrow youtube too
i know hey what's his name bo burnham
did too oh right
yeah he was a youtuber yeah yeah just
shows when you have actual talent you
can break out
[Laughter]
and we're here we sometimes think yeah
when you have like
some talent you know you can stay here
yeah contentment do you consider
yourself a tuber or an instagrammer or a
tick-tocker
or i mean i my biggest following is on
take talk
so a lot of times people are like oh
she's a tick tocker but i started on
like
youtube but my youtube isn't like it's
pretty small it's like 20 000
subscribers
yeah it's really small yeah so it's like
it's a little tiny thing a little pee in
the
little bucket you know but um but what
about your tick tock how big is your
tick tock
like three hundred thousand yeah it's
pretty good for like you know
it's great it's a pandemic thing yeah i
love it but you just started last year
though
yeah for the tic-tac-toe yeah i don't
even know how to do no tick tocks
dude the best thing though is being in a
room with og youtubers who are like
these tick-tock people
it happens a lot it happens a lot it's
so hard to tell people have a tick tock
but at the same time like i
used to talk so much yeah that i love it
as a platform in that room i will take a
dump in their mouth
everybody wants to be a tick tocker now
though that's the thing they just don't
want to admit it
yeah i've had a lot of people [ __ ] and
then now they have tic tacs they're like
oh make sure to follow my tick tock
i can't believe i haven't it's just a
different medium that's all it is i'm
like you still did air band it was just
for three minutes longer than what
they're doing
why are you doing this and a lot of
content that works on youtube if you cut
it
to follow tick tock it works the same
way because yeah it's just people hungry
for like quick content that they want to
see right
that's what a lot of podcasters do now
the podcast comedy podcast they'll like
take little clips and then put it back
on some subtitles and you're good to go
yeah and then it goes viral
it's like fun stuff to watch i love to
talk yeah well i wonder what the next
thing is going on
too much work well uncle sam because
you've been doing it for so long
i know maybe it's because you've knew
for so long and also like i don't know i
feel like it's such a like i have to put
my bifocals on to [ __ ] work on this
[ __ ]
i remember the when vine first came out
like when vine first came out
and this is old too because it's vine
right i was like how the [ __ ] do you do
this goddamn vine thing and i remember
like
six seconds so i just had my first vine
ever was just my dog wagging its tail
for six seconds i was like
i guess i made a vine and i don't know
how to do [ __ ]
[Music]
do
you